Transcriptor: Julio Delgadillo
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
(Música)
Hay muchas formas de volar.
Hay quién nace con alas
y no las sabe usar,
quién las tiene y no las quiere.
Hay también en este mundo
quién contempla el horizonte.
Quién sabe volar sin alas
con la imaginación, con los sueños
con los caminos andados.
Hay quién está esperando
un rayo de luz para invadir el cielo
apropiarse de él
infectar al mundo de libertad.
Hay también quién construye sus alas
quién no cesa de intentar
quién no tiene miedo a los abismos
por qué confía en sus alas
aunque estén rotas o gastadas.
Hay también quién tiene sus alas
en lugares inimaginables.
Las alas no solo son de las aves,
ni de los que vuelan,
las alas están en nuestra mente
esperando despertar para hacernos
libres, ligeros, plenos, felices
¿De qué color son tus alas?
Existen voces dentro de nosotros
nos hablan, nos gritan, nos piden vivir.
Esas voces nunca se callan porque
nuestros sueños están hechos
de nuestros anhelos,
de nuestros deseos o necesidades.
De nuestros recuerdos primigenios,
en algún momento de nuestra historia
de vida, se engendraron y piden vivir.
Pero para hablar en el mundo real
y en el lenguaje cotidiano, toda idea
que no da para vivir
está condenada a morir.
Porque la realidad es que tenemos que
enfrentar situaciones prioritarias
como la superviviencia.
Esa es la llave para que nuestros sueños
sean nuestra vida, construir un puente
entre el mundo de
nuestros sueños y la supervivencia.
Sí es posible aunque parezca descabellado,
yo un día soñé que era posible transformar
el mundo, que era posible crear seres
humanos mejores, entrar en el interior
de las personas y poderles ofrecer
sensibilidad, imaginación y cualquier otro
sentimiento que ayudara a mejorar
esta sociedad. Y para aterrizar mi sueño
en acciones reales lo primero
que tuve que hacer es decir,
¿desde dónde puedo trabajar?,
¿desde dónde puedo yo
aportar con todo lo que soy?
Mark Twain dijo: "Hay dos días importantes
en tu vida, el día que naces y el día
que descubres para qué". En esta búsqueda
interna, yo encontré el mundo de
los títeres que dieron carne a mi sueño.
Los títeres me enseñaron que era posible
entrar en el interior de las personas,
transformarlas, tocarlas, mostrar
un mundo diferente, lleno de imaginación.
Eso dio resultado
al mayor discurso de mi profesión.
Yo no puedo cambiar lo que te sucede,
lo que sí puedo hacer es
mostrarte que hay otros mundos,
que hay otros lugares donde es posible
la imaginación, la fantasía.
Es posible convertir la ira, la violencia,
la desesperanza en colores,
en movimientos, en diálogos.
El mundo de los títeres para mí
se convirtió en todas las artes juntas
y creo de verdad con todo mi corazón que
es posible transformar el mundo si nos
transformamos nosotros desde adentro,
el arte entra con fuerza a las personas y
se queda ahí, nos hace sentir vivos, nos
hace sentir más humanos, nos
conecta con nuestro ayer, nuestro ahora
y nos construye para el mañana.
Y bueno, teniendo este discurso en la piel
me puse a trabajar,
me puse a bocetear mis alas,
y sí encontré mi proyecto, que es
"Casa de los Títeres Monini", es un foro
creado para funciones de títeres.
Así de loquísimo está mi sueño.
Y bueno, lo primero que entendí fue que
la seriedad con la que yo trataba
mis sueños, era la seriedad
con la que iba a percibir el mundo,
mi entorno, a las personas cerca de mí.
Me puse a trabajar, me puse a estructurar,
lo primero que hice fue responderme
una pregunta muy importante: ¿para qué
quiero hacer esto? Y Chris Anderson, dice
algo muy importante
en una de sus conferencias:
"Nuestras ideas nos forman
una visión personal del mundo",
¿qué quiere decir esto?
que cuando nosotros
tenemos consciencia de lo que somos,
de nuestros anhelos y de nuestros deseos,
todo se vuelve real,
todo se vuelve tangible y realizable.
Nosotros decimos coloquialmente:
"estamos conectados con el universo".
Y de pronto cuando empezamos a realizar
nuestro sueños, todo se nos da fácilmente,
se nos acercan personas, empieza a suceder
toda la magia. Lo que sucede en realidad
es que nuestro cerebro empieza a detectar
cualquier idea que refuerce o complemente
y que nos haga ver que es posible lo que
estamos haciendo, nuestra idea es posible.
Por ejemplo, cuando tenemos la idea de
un embarazo no deseado, y andamos
por la calle, se nos cruzan señoras
con bebés, con carritos de bebés,
vemos con carritos, vemos pruebas
de embarazo,
vemos escaparates llenos
de productos para bebés,
todo eso siempre ha estado ahí,
nada más que
a nuestro cerebro no le ocupaba esa idea.
Cuando nosotros nos conectamos,
ese proceso pasa dentro de nosotros, y
esto fue lo primero que yo pensé:
"Voy a realizar mis sueños
y voy a estructurar".
¿Cómo empecé a estructurar?
Lo primero que hice fue
investigar absolutamente todo sobre
el tema, documentarme,
entrevistarme con personas que
habían hecho proyectos similares al mío,
y descubrí una verdad maravillosa.
Hay un montón de gente
alrededor del mundo viviendo sus sueños
y realizando proyectos
muy similares a los míos
y que esas personas estaban
ansiosas de compartir su idea,
de ayudarme, de empujarme
para que yo pudiera realizar mis sueños.
Una vez que me documenté, me preparé,
investigué todo lo referente al tema,
lo que hice fue planificar.
Planificar el tiempo y
ver qué tenía y que no tenía,
dónde iba a realizarlo,
cómo lo iba a realizar,
cuántas personas necesitaba,.
Cada sueño tiene su tiempo, su latir
y su tiempo de gestación.
Tenemos que ser
muy pacientes y muy congruentes,
poner muchas fechas para nosotros
irnos empujando a llegar a esta meta.
Una vez que planifiqué,
una vez que investigué y documenté,
lo siguiente fue ubicar muy bien
mi proyecto, decir cuál era mi producto.
Porque puede ser el sueño más absurdo,
más ambiguo y más inverosímil
que puedan ver las personas, pero
lo cierto es que si hubiera una etiqueta
colgando de cada sueño exitoso realizado
diría: "99 % trabajo
1 % idea original".
Nosotros tenemos que estar muy conscientes
que tenemos que luchar por lo que somos.
Me preparé, me documenté, hice
contabilidad de mis años, de mis dineros,
de mi trabajo y abrí
"Casa de los Títeres Monini"
Llegó el día de la inauguración,
todo mundo estuvo feliz, contento.
Al día siguiente con la sobriedad del día
después, me levanté,
me paré frente al espejo y dije:
"Dios mío, ¿qué hice?
¡Estoy loca! Pero respiré, estaba muy
consciente, ¡muy consciente! de
lo que estaba haciendo y
lo hice con todas mis fuerzas.
Respiré y regresé a la vida.
A los dos días, una persona tocó a la
puerta, y me dijo:
"Oiga, ¿Ud. hace títeres? ¿Me puede hacer
este títere?" Y me enseñó una foto.
Lógicamente lo que pensé es que mi madre
había pagado a esa persona o
mi marido la había mandado para que
yo no perdiera la esperanza pero no,
esta persona era real, y empezó
toda una vida alrededor de mi sueño.
Todo puede comenzar con un primer impulso,
si tú tienes consciencia de esto, nunca
jamás vas a abandonar tu sueño.
La vida te va a llevar por muchos rumbos,
lo importante es
saber muy bien a dónde vas.
Porque así nunca vas a olvidar tu camino,
ese camino que te lleva
a la única verdad de tu vida, qué es
quiénes somos, lo que hacemos
y para qué lo hacemos.
Hay muchas formas de volar.